[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
tonight
[Music]
no i appreciate it
[Music]
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay yeah
[Music]
[Music]
let's go over here
[Music]
thank you
like um was that
[Music]
dude
that makes sense
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
of
um
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
lily
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
oh
oh
um
[Music]
oh
how could you forget that
[Music]
oh my god everyone's all together
okay
[Music]
[Music]
yeah let's do this more quickly
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hey
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
let me first unmute myself
good morning yo college class of 2021.
let's go
welcome to the graduates of grace hopper
jonathan edwards trumbull
silliman and ezra styles college
who are arrived on old campus to begin
our ceremony
and welcome to family friends and
members of the class
who are joining us virtually today via
live stream
we are so excited to have arrived on
this special day
in a few moments we will begin
announcing the graduates
as they process across the commencement
stage here in front of me
before we start our program a few words
about the land on which today's ceremony
is taking place
yale acknowledges that indigenous
peoples and nations
including mohegan mashintaka pequot
eastern pequot scattercock golden hill
pagosa
niantic and the quinnipiac and other
algonquin speaking peoples
have stewarded through generations the
lands and waterways
of what is now the state of connecticut
we honor and respect
the enduring relationship that exists
between these peoples
and nations and this land thank you and
please enjoy the program
okay mr president i have the honor to
present
candidates from trumbull college for the
bachelor's degrees
in yale college when they have been
recommended by the faculty of yale
college
and approved by the corporation dean
chun
will ask you by your official act to
confer
upon them these degrees by the authority
vested in me
i shall confer upon you the bachelor's
degrees in yale college
when designated by the dean and shall
then admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
jeffrey joe the banner bearer of
trumbull college
claire lamarr and marcus sack the
procession marshals of trumbull college
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jacob dean asher
[Music]
gianna baez
jeremy barron
sarah break bill hackey
sam bringham
darien colby carrington
cal christophori
dale chung
caleb cohen
vinicius da silva
[Applause]
[Music]
hannah geller
lauren gilinov
carajan
adia klein
hunter cohn catherine
cosey taj
phillip lakey
abigail leonard
alan liu
hannah mans
mitchell mayers
gabriela mancillo
ria mattel
caroline moore
[Music]
jewel moore
[Music]
vishnu murali
jonathan murillo
grant negli
obdk norum jr
max of music
elida orhan
[Applause]
june park
rachira ray
zarya janae rogers
[Applause]
[Music]
mariko fujimutu fujimoto rooks melvin
ross
nicolas andres ruiz widobro
magditz
daniel sanchez
johanna shen
jeremy robert irwin sanchi
ricardo aaron soto
[Music]
charles tenenbaum
griffin coolidge thomas
rodney thomas ii
jared guangchan trong
peter van der slice
ava vanick
anushka walia
angelica walker
[Applause]
alexander whitaker
adam vonkowski
christopher shui
eric you shall
[Applause]
congratulations trombolians mura
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates from grace hopper college
for the bachelor's degrees in yale
college
when they have been recommended by the
faculty of yale college
and approved by the corporation dean
chan will ask you by your official act
to confer upon them these degrees
[Music]
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you the bachelor's degrees
in yale college when designated by the
dean
and shall then admit you to all their
rights
and responsibilities
sheldon zou the banner bearer of grace
hopper college
and megan the procession marshals of
grace hopper college
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
marcain barnett
ryan elizabeth benson
alma maya bitran
kun yun antonio bong
timothy carter bradley
elias
patrick andres cherry
rachel allegra cohen
john harmon cooper
robert sebastian crystal
formosa deppman
samuel harris essig
ryan ann eversol
julian matteo fernandez
indira amani flores
charles bernard foster
drew gauls nihar
jayesh gandhi
michael edward garvey
lauren gada
zachary jason gold yes
vivek gopalan
[Music]
robert james sherman howard
j.j howland
charlotte ann heilinski
talis gardener ayu ayorio roneg
raeshawn antoine johnson jr
olivia danielle joraj
samuel landino sophie
elspith morton latham
paige julia lawrence
melissa leone marlika alta gracia
marceau
michael martinez
john christian pierre maple
julia catherine mcclellan
dalia muahlin
garcia
elizabeth nectarline alejandro nuno
daryl luis manuel pona
dean perseverenda butong
[Music]
d major roman
miriam aviva ross
anika karina salmi
katherine wright schmeckel
brandon david scott
kiara nicole spain
[Applause]
srivas simon
lee stone eric
kenji takada
tiava marco torres
lynn sanderton
[Applause]
nancy catherine wallicky
eric wallach
carly wana
corey wu
vivian yee
amber pascal young
[Applause]
jordan craig young
[Music]
and the graduates who are participating
remotely
mary elizabeth barnett
faith chumo
[Applause]
congratulations grace hopper college
class of 2021.
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates from jonathan edwards college
for the bachelor's degrees in yale
college when they have been recommended
by the faculty of yale college
and approved by the corporation dean
chun
will ask you upon your by your official
act to confer upon them
these degrees
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you the bachelor's degrees
in yale college
when designated by the dean and shall
then admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
anna j sun the banner bearer of jonathan
edwards college
shimasuka chica victory oba jessie
and stephen daniel orientale the
procession marshals
of jonathan edwards college
fiona eileen asbury
[Applause]
natalie beauchamp
griffin bowen berlin
lydia burleson
[Applause]
akshi chaba
[Music]
simmer preet
[Applause]
mackenzie marie cooke
caitlin nicole corfman
catherine livingston cutler
nicholas bayard cutler jr
shiroke daniel
[Music]
[Applause]
kate maureen donovan
dustin kent dunaway
lena h gallagher
marcos gazepis
alina jennifer mila glaubitz
mia nickay jackson gregory
johnny kitty
can anna sophia
kane jake lawrence kaladner
matthew joseph lamarrand
johnny winley
taysu daniel lee
kevin g lee
heidi mclooff charles
paul markert diego
martell samantha
jane martinelli nicholas
chandler marwell alexandra
nicole mcraven
luke ian mckenna
jillian eve malmon
rose milo lauren
moriyama hong fu
win jesutomi
odukoya christina
beatrice otero
jessica taylor pavner
[Music]
hoytham tuanvo
chopham
cornelia brainard rogers
nicholas victor sarambana
aditi krishni shetty
calvin blake solomon
[Applause]
sophia suarez
alexa sabrina sai
vera jung villanueva
miles xavier waits
emma louisa wilson
why penn wong angela chao
alice zao
and the graduates participating remotely
jennifer guadalupe duenas
mark anthony windhoffer shang yi
zhang congratulations je
class of 2021
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates
from silliman college for the bachelor's
degree
in yale college when they have been
recommended by the faculty of yale
college
and approved by the corporation din chun
will ask by your official act to confer
upon them
these degrees
[Applause]
[Music]
by the authority vested in me i
shall confer upon you the bachelor's
degrees in yale college when designated
by the dean
and shall then admit you to all their
rights
and responsibilities
brooke catherine milosh the banner
bearer of silliman college
camila andrea torro and corey mark
zao the procession marshalls of silliman
college
sir
al ali avery
l arena aurora
taylor as a dorian
joke sing batra
[Music]
daniel matthew blatt
natalie jane boyer
emma marie brody
joseph antonio brownsberger
okay brenda
kevin chen
[Music]
catherine d cluello
jesus contreras
[Music]
[Applause]
andre l costa
john dean
olivia drubner
farah marie emery muhammad
[Music]
[Applause]
darlene maria gomez
kania danielle hale
[Music]
deonte demond henson
samantha higgins
stephanie boma horsefall
lillian hua
jacob koppelman hutt
robert william darling
brett william jewell
anthony leon g
sung me anna johnson
[Applause]
christina cow connor
jacob kennedy j.p
kenny emery david
carrakesh
[Music]
caroline kim
[Music]
lauren kim
[Music]
stanley junlong lamb
abigail vivian lee
araceli a lopez
brandon liu
thomas duke martin
matthew bassam massad
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
gregory connor naruto
maggie k nolan
emily
[Music]
samuel brooks calabrese
alice park
jordan christine pilant
william r polsky
johan popov peter
prestacos andrew
james roshan
catherine jens sawkins
bavesh
[Music]
olivia shoemaker
vasilios platten siophus
[Music]
slater adams smith
kelly ann speltz
hiristo svetoslav steikoff
henry steven suko ziemer
james gian son
martin daley tipton
teodora
[Applause]
[Music]
aaron joshua wade
tom valenstein
kenneth wang xavier
tariq washington
thomas bailey weasler
jason yang
[Applause]
[Music]
jennifer y yoon
dana zamir
and mate j jilanka
the graduates participating remotely are
darcy
shannon
son congratulations class of 2021.
mr president i have the honor
to present candidates from ezra
styles college for the bachelor's
degrees
in yale college when they have been
recommended
by the faculty of yale college and
approved by the corporation
dean chun will ask you by your official
act
to confer upon them these degrees
[Applause]
[Music]
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you the bachelor's degrees
in yale college
when designated by the dean and shall
then
admit you to all their rights
and responsibilities
covert james geary jr the banner bearer
of ezra styles college
gabriella blatt and luta fastdog the
procession marshals of ezra styles
college
grace ellen aronson
[Applause]
jacob angelo abdullah
[Applause]
jack adam alessandra
sophia aguirre
teresa erica parhamville
bessie maria bauman
brittany marie bustis
sophia eva bleak
greta kirby brown
brandon robert canfield
martin stewart chandler
[Applause]
joseph leo class alexander
nathan cohen
nathaniel alexander cuevas
[Music]
ivt duong
[Music]
iv victoria fan
alyssa nicole firth
veronica e galenberti
[Music]
raymond liu gao
simon alexander gabrielesis
abigail gertrude gundrum
grant theodore halliday the second
elani burnett harris
[Music]
charles townsend hardy hawkins
jacqueline de los mercedes hair perez
phillip edward hinkis
logan mclean howard
cassandra xiao
catherine who alejandro antonio hocko
emily yinwin g
emily elizabeth johnson
jaeger mario johnson
[Music]
darren meshach larom jones
zachary dakota jones
alicia radha kacharia
yuki kawamura
andrew peter kazimchak
joanna petrova lazarova
isabelle jin hee lee
jin lee okay emily lynn
lawrence dashau lou cameron morgan
luther
sarah jane luceriaga
sabrina liz macias
[Music]
mary claire mcmahon brittany
miranda manjavar kellen
m merman bunnell anna graves milliken
andy moe mohammed hassan mohammed
isabel marie monroy
vikram mullick sophia
shia nam jose navas
peter necrossaf max
daniel noble
alexandria bella noble
corral lynn ortiz
nolan patrick padin
marissa alexis purrier
kaylee g pillinger lorenzo penasco
ferreros
andrew jordan vida prinster
ivana pristick sudjan
nariana ramanathan
astaire reyes kobe
james rizwick
[Applause]
carolyn elizabeth j he sacco
isabel salinas ariola
emily hope showtime benjamin cole
shelton
javon matthew tafoya
helen s tegan
renee jessica tong zachary logan wade
[Applause]
samantha jimenez westfall
nia aderinka whitmall
jonathan wu emily hanshu
cheithan sanjay yadav
alec gray zabornak
oasis position jen
benjamin kaihua joe
christopher zillow
[Applause]
and the graduates participating remotely
aaron hong-joo
choi jason andrew good juan juan ho
joseph kwon ariel alyssa
tessier max wong lee clark
sia go ezra styles
to the students of the class of 2021
and their parents families and friends
looking on from
around the globe we gather to recognize
the extraordinary
accomplishments of all of you who have
worked so hard to complete your programs
of study we salute your efforts
your diligence your talent
and your intellect we also join you in
expressing gratitude
for all who have supported you in these
endeavors
your families and friends teachers
and other members of the yale community
congratulations class of 2021
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
hello class of 2021 my name is stephen
orientale
and i am a member of the class day
committee and the senior class council
four years have gone by in the blink of
an eye
we've made so many memories from the
first year snowball fight on old campus
right here
to the yale harvard football game of
2019 where we won in double
overtime to all of the late nights
whether they'd be in the library
studying for an exam
or in the common rooms talking with our
friends and suite mates
although our senior year experience was
certainly not a traditional one
the class of 2021 made the best of the
situation
when we leave yale in just a few days we
will leave with memories and friendships
that will last a lifetime
here's to the class of 2021 we did it
class of 2021 good morning my name is
stanley lamb
and i'm jin lee and we are members of
the committee that organized class day
which will air on youtube tomorrow at 2
30 p.m
two minutes before 2 30 at 2 28 pm
a special piece written by our class a
speaker robert lopez will be played from
harkness tower so keep your ears open
if you haven't already decorated a funny
hat for class day it's not too late
in fact on your seat today you received
a class day 2021 hat that you might want
to use just for that purpose
you'll also find a gift bag which
includes items that represent
long-standing class day traditions
as well as others that are new and
unique to the class of 2021
in addition to the class a speaker
tomorrow's program also includes remarks
by members of our class
who have put together outstanding
original speeches
and because class day is about all of us
you'll see your photographs and video
reflections throughout tomorrow's
program congratulations class of 2021
and see you at class day
class of 2021 congratulations again
i am so happy to be with you and to
celebrate with you today
graduating is a great accomplishment uh
one of the most important ones of your
life
and if you think back to when you first
arrived on campus
no one could have imagined that you
would live through a global pandemic
before reaching this moment
but you did and thanks to your strength
and perseverance
this moment has finally come i am
honored to recognize
all the work that you have done to get
here much of it with the support
of your family and friends so today is
your day
and it is theirs too today is a day for
looking back with pride
at everything you have accomplished and
all the goals you have reached
of course it brings some sadness too now
that you are ending your bright
college years but today is a
commencement
a beginning so now as you look to the
days and years ahead
think of the new achievements and
opportunities in front of you
and look around as well to remind
yourself
of the excellent company joining you on
the new beginning
your friendships formed at yale
tomorrow you will celebrate class day a
tradition stretching back
150 years in yell college history i'm
excited to watch the virtual program
along with you
and on monday we can look forward to
president salovey's
commencement address i am grateful to
the class day committee to the senior
class council
to the university secretary's office to
your college heads and deans
and to everyone who contributed to
making the special events
of this weekend possible and i'm most
appreciative to you
for all that you have brought to yale
and will now bring out into the world
with you
again class of 2021 congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
next
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
wow
[Music]
let's roll
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
don't worry about the alphabet anymore
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
there's actually there's actually a
spare run over there i think it's 17
my mic is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you